رفض مصدر بالامم المتحده للجزيره بوصول
موظفين من جنسيات مختلفه يعملون في
المنظمه الدوليه ومنظمات اخرى الى انجمينا
عاصمه تشاد قادمين من شمال دارفور غربيه
السودان وقد اوضح المصدر ان الموظفين
الذين وصلوا الى كانوا عالقين في مدينه
الفاشر منذ اندلاع المعارك بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع واضافان عمليه
الاجلاء تمت باستخدام طائر العسكريه
فرنسيه من مطار الفاشل الى مطار انجنينه
ومنه الى مطار نيروبي في كينيا
من امام مقر وزاره الخارجيه في باريس
مراسل الجزيره نور الدين بوزيان ينضم
الينا الان نور الدين اهلا بك المزيد معك
ربما حول هذا الاسهام الفرنسي في عمليه
الاجلاء في السودان
سفيان المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
قبل نحو ساعتين قلت لها هل من معلومات
اضافيه حول هذه العمليه عمليه اجلاء
دبلوماسيه تابعينا للامم المتحده ومنظمات
غير حكوميه مع عائلاتهم طبعا اكدت ذلك
وقالت بان الامم المتحده تشكر خاصه فرنسا
على ما قامت به عندما نقلت واجلت عدد من
دبلوماسيه من بورس السودان باتجاه الطرف
الاخر من البحر الاحمر اي جده السعوديه لا
معلومات دقيقه عن العدد وعن الكيفيه التي
تم بها اجراء هؤلاء علمنا بان طائره فعلا
باتجاه التشاد تعرف جيدا بان لفرنسا قاعده
كبيره في التشاد وايضا هذه القاعده توجد
في حاله طوارئ منذ ان بد قبل اسبوعين
فرنسا تحركات انطلاقا من جيبوتي حيث ارسلت
ثلاث طائرات من اجل اجلاء رعاياها ورعايا
اوروبيين ولكن بالنسبه للذين نقلوا او تم
اجلائهم من بر السودان من المؤكد ان هذا
الموكب الذي حملهم ورفقهم لم يكن يعني
مرافقه فرنسيه وانما وصل الى السودان ومن
هناك تم اجلاء هؤلاء الدبلوماسيين
الامميين اللافت سفيان بان باريس لا زال
لا تزال تؤكد التالي بان موظفي الامم
المتحده لا يجب ان يشكل هدفا وان فرنسا
تدين عمليه السطو على مخزون الاغذيه
والمساعدات الانسانيه وتطالب بوقف ذلك
دبلوماسيه لا تزال فرنسا كما تقول
الخارجيه الفرنسيه في تواصل مع مختلف
الشركاء
والحلفاء من اجل كما تقول باريس تثبيت وقف
اطلاق النار لكن الانطباع السائد عندما
تتحدث سفيان جانبا بعيدا عن الكاميرا
والمايكروفون يقول لك الدبلوماسيون
الفرنسيون بان لديهم قناعه من ان البرهان
كما حميتي يعتقدان بان احدهما سيفوز على
الاخر وبالتالي يظنني بانه لا يعني
السلاح الان مدام كله طرف يعتقد ويظن بانه
سيفوز في هذه المعركه اضيف فقط من المواقف
الفرنسيه هو ضروره تثبيت الهدنه لان باريس
كما تعلم تخشى الان وهذا الذي اكده احد
المتحدثين باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه قبل
ايام للجزيره تخشى ان يعني تكون اصداء غير
ماموله لما يجري الان في السودان على
الجوار والاقليم المباشر وتحديدا تشاد
ويقول متحدث باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه بان
باريس لا يمكنها القبول اولا بالامر
الواقع الذي
سينجم من خلال استخدام السلاح ويضيف بان
المنطقه هشه ورخوه ولا بد ان ترجع الاطراف
المعنيه الى طاوله المفاوضات ويتحدث عن
وجود اجماع لدى المجموعه الدوليه من اجل
ايجاد مخرج سلمى وديبلوماسي لهذا النزاع
المسلح شكرا